so remember that set announcement
servlet that you created earlier now
you're going to set up cron job to run
it regularly say every minute every ten
minutes whatever to update the
announcement so to set up your cron job
you're going to need to create a cron
dot XML file and configure it to run /
cron / set announcement because that's
the path that we set up for us at set
announcement function and then specify
the schedule let's say once per minute
the development server on localhost
doesn't run cron jobs so when you're
ready go ahead and deploy your app to
appspot then add one or more conferences
that have between 0 and 5 seats
available and the easiest way to do that
is just to create a new conference with
max attendees less than five then use
the cron viewer in the admin console to
make sure that your cron jobs running
and then of course go ahead and get the
latest announcement to check that the
latest announcement did get updated and
you can do this either you can use
either the memcache viewer all the api's
console to get the latest announcement
so now your cron jobs humming along
it'll keep going by itself that means
it's going to run a query to look for
conferences every minute or however
often you scheduled it to run it's
helpful for learning purposes to see the
cron job running frequently but it's not
a good practice to leave cron jobs
running more frequently than you really
need them this cron job does a fairly
simple query and then puts a value in
memcache which is no daily quota but if
your cron job did something that
intensively hit the datastore it could
easily use up much more quota so you
need to think about what your cron jobs
do and how often they need to run I've
accidentally used up my entire daily
quota running a cron job that searched
all the conferences and save results in
the datastore so I learned my lesson the
hard way so go ahead and change the
frequency to once an hour and when
you've done that come over here and
check this box alternatively you could
disable the cron job completely by
uploading an empty cron job config but
remember if you just delete the cron
config file completely then the one
that's already up on appspot stays
running so one more quick quiz how do
you schedule your cron job to run once
every two hours go ahead and enter that
value in here and that's it for Cronkite